[Applaudissements]
bonjour vous vous demandez ce que j'ai
dans ma boîte
c'est un cerveau
et pas n'importe lequel c'est mon
cerveau mon hémisphère droit
c'est avec une irm et une imprimante 3d
qu'on peut réaliser ce genre de tour de
passe passe et je vais même vous montrer
en grand sans aucune inhibition
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce strip tease un
peu particulier ne porte pas la
conséquence à moins que ce soit
gravement malade un neurologue ou un
psychiatre qui a regardé ces images il
pourrait rien en conclure sur mes
faiblesses éventuelles
est-ce que je vais évoquer avec vous
aujourd'hui c'est que ça va changer
il est probablement plus rapidement vous
imaginez en fait ces images irm
elles contiennent des informations qui
permettent de détecter les prémices des
maladies et les détecter avant même les
symptômes c'est une avancée majeure
parce que bien sûr on a beaucoup plus de
chances de contrecarrer une maladie si
on la détecte preto et malheureusement
un tiers d'entre nous un jour sera
confronté à une maladie du cerveau
alors pour vous aider à prendre
conscience collectivement de ce que ça
veut dire
j'ai demandé de lever la main aux gens
dont approche est touché par une de ces
maladies ou a été touchée par une de ces
malades vous avez compris
on peut pas se permettre de laisser
passer une opportunité de mieux les
gérer
alors irm
ça veut dire imagerie par résonance
magnétique résonance magnétique
pourquoi cette association étrange la
bonne nouvelle c'est que c'est facile à
comprendre
vous savez peut-être que nous sommes
truffé de petits aimants les atomes qui
composent nos corps ont souvent cette
propriété et c'est en vous annonçant
dans un énorme champ magnétique qu'on
peut en tirer parti pour faire des
images
alors quand je dis énorme je parle de
dix mille fois le champ magnétique de la
terre
celui qui fait tourner les aiguilles des
boussoles
dans le tunnel d'une irm si on excepte
vos petits aimants il se mettra
raisonnée et la magie de l'histoire
c'est qu'on peut capter la musique
qu'ils émettent
avec une antenne alors la seule
fréquence qui permet d'agir sur eux
d'obtenir cette résonance elle est
proportionnelle à la force du champ
magnétique et le truc des physiciens qui
ont inventé l'irm
ça a été de faire varier légèrement
champs magnétiques dans l'espace pour
que chaque partie de votre cerveau et
met une note différente et le tour est
joué
l'intensité de chaque note va décider
d'intensité de chaque pixel de l'image
je vais pas en dire plus sur cette
résonance magnétique parce que ce que je
veux vraiment vous décrire aujourd'hui
c'est l'émergence d'un nouveau phénomène
de résonance
je vais vous raconter comment les sorts
de l'intelligence artificielle est en
passe de faire résonner la totalité
demande de lire en fête c'est exactement
la technologie qui manquait pour saisir
une opportunité dont je parlais tout à
l'heure pour extraire tout le jus d'une
irm du cerveau et voir les maladies à
leur tout premier stade alors tout à
l'heure je vous ai un peu monté ce que
vous voyez derrière moi c'est pas
vraiment mon cerveau en fait c'est mon
cerveau il ya une vingtaine d'années un
jour où j'ai participé à une expérience
dans le laboratoire où je travaillais et
depuis il a changé
il change chaque année chaque jour
chaque minute ils changent tout le temps
et la chance qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
qu'avec l'irm on peut voir une grande
partie de ces changements
même avec l'image aussi simple que
l'image anatomy que vous voyez des
herbes
il suffit de réaliser une image avant et
après un apprentissage suffisamment
intensifs et de les comparer les
chercheurs ont montré par exemple que si
j'apprenais à jongler mettons une heure
par jour pendant quelques semaines il se
passerait quelque chose à l'arrière de
mon cerveau la partie qui me sert à
percevoir les choses qui bougent
pendant que j'apprends à jongler va se
mettre à gonfler littéralement parce que
les neurones qu'elle contient ils vont
développer des nouvelles connexions pour
m'aider à mémoriser ce que j'apprends et
que toutes les cellules autour qui les
nourrissent
on se développer en conséquence est que
tout ça prend de la place et ça marche
dans les deux sens une partie de votre
cerveau que vous négligez qui ne
travaillent pas à celle avoir tendance à
se ratatine vous avez tout est entre vos
mains vous pouvez moduler le
développement de votre cerveau en
choisissant vos comportements
un peu comme on peu se sculpter un corps
d'athlète en allant dans une salle de
gym
pensez-y en multipliant les pensées
positives vous allez muscler votre
cerveau pour cet état d'esprit et vous
allez revenir plus facilement alors
moins réjouissant notre cerveau il
change aussi parce qu'en vieillissant on
perd régulièrement des neurones j'ai dit
moins réjouissant en fait j'ai tort
parce que pour la plupart d'entre nous
ça n'a pas de conséquence ce que fait
notre cerveau probablement se
débarrasser des neurones inutile
peut-être de ceux qui font beaucoup de
bruit pour rien tout cela pour nous
emmener sur la voie de la sagesse qu'on
découvre petit à petit avec l'âge mais
quand on n'a pas de chance on peut
s'engager sur une pente plus harmonieuse
des neurones se mettent à disparaître à
différents endroits dans le cerveau trop
vite
c'est le début d'une malade et
heureusement pendant longtemps souvent
des années on se rend compte de rien
parce que le cerveau est très très
résilient et puis un jour les premiers
symptômes apparaissent
un autre jour ils deviennent
suffisamment dérangeant pour qu'on y
voir un médecin
et puis un jour de médecins va prescrire
unir un radiologue va la regarder
il va pas voir grand chose à moins que
vous soyez un stade avancé des maladies
les changements dont je parle
ils sont trop ténus pour que le
radiologue et perçoivent et si vous
regardez le cerveau derrière moi d'un
patient atteint de la maladie
d'alzheimer et un stade très élevé très
grave
vous voyez peut-être que ces sillons
sont plus ouverts que les autres mais
même cela c'est assez difficile à
percevoir alors vous devez commencer à
santé où je veux en venir
lire ml existe déjà depuis 30 ans et on
est des millions à avoir eu droit à une
photo de notre cerveau tout est en place
pour que demain ce ne soit plus un
radiologue qui est qui regarde ces
images pour évaluer la situation quand
vous passez unir
si vous avez feuilleter un carnet de
santé ces derniers temps vous avez
peut-être remarqué ce graphique derrière
moi
qui décrit comment le périmètre crânien
des enfants évoluent avec l'âge
et quand un enfant s'éloigne trop de la
norme c'est un signal d' alerte son
pédiatre à vas prescrire des examens
complémentaires pour comprendre ce qui
se passe bien avec l'irm on peut faire
des milliers graphique de ce genre et
bien sûr un radiologue sol confronté à
cette avalanche de chiffres va pas
réussir à extraire du sens et c'est
précisément là que ses algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle dont on
parle aujourd'hui au quotidien vont
jouer leur rôle ils vont transformer ces
milliers de chiffres en une détection
des premiers signes de maladie alors
bien sûr ça va pas suffire pour les
guérir mais ça va ouvrir une fenêtre
d'opportunités parce que si on s'attaque
à une maladie avant qu'elle ait fait des
dégâts majeurs on a beaucoup beaucoup
plus de chances d'arrêter les dégâts et
il n'est pas impossible qu'un jour ces
images du cerveau
elles servent comme un outil de
dépistage un peu comme la mammographie
aujourd'hui alors jusqu'à présent j'ai
parlé uniquement des maladies qui
surviennent quand on vieillit et qu'on
peut détecter par irm
parce qu'elles détruisent des neurones
est-ce qu'on aurait une chance également
de détecter ce qu'on appelle les
pathologies du développement les
pathologies qui surviennent parce que
dans le ventre de notre mère pendant la
construction de notre cerveau
quelque chose peut aller travers les
images jaune que vous voyez au centre du
colimaçon c'est des images de très
grands prématurés
aujourd'hui c'est assez incroyable on
peut les sauver quand ils naissent à
moins de six mois de grossesse et vous
pouvez constater que quand ils laissent
leur cerveau est quasiment lisse parce
qu'en fait c'est pendant le dernier
trimestre de grossesse que le cerveau
des hommes se plissent chez chacun
d'entre nous ce placement est unique on
pourrait vous reconnaître vous
reconnaître en regardant votre cerveau
au même titre qu'on peut vous
reconnaître avec vos empreintes
digitales alors bien sûr ça serait pas
très utile par exemple pour débloquer
votre téléphone
mais quelque chose de plus intéressant
c'est que ça pourrait permettre de
découvrir un plissement un motif de
peace man inhabituels qui pourraient
mettre le doigt sur une faiblesse qu'on
pourrait peut-être contrecarrer avant
qu'elle se manifeste
si vous regardez un peu plus
attentivement les cerveaux hongrie de
mon colimaçon qui vont de la naissance
au grand âge vous voyez effectivement
qu'ils sont tous plissée différemment
même si on voit une espèce d air de
famille une carte routière si j'ose dire
qui est propre à l'espèce humaine
mais chacun d'entre eux à des
modifications de cette carte routière et
aujourd'hui on sait pas les interpréter
les six se trouvent ya rien à
interpréter parce qu'au fond ces plis du
cortex c'est un truc que la nature a
trouvé pour augmenter la taille de notre
cortex probablement pour nous rendre
plus intelligent et elle a fait ça en
gardant à notre tête une taille
raisonnable pour concours pas un risque
majeur à la naissance et pour la plupart
des gens ça suffit à expliquer ces
plissement mais depuis quelques temps un
certain nombre de découvertes tendent à
prouver qu'il y a plus que ça une espèce
de tectonique du cerveau qui conduit ses
plis en fait à refléter des spécificités
de l'organisation de cet énorme réseau
de neurones qui constitue notre cerveau
par exemple sur ces images vous voyez ce
qu'on découvert des radiologues de
l'hôpital sainte anne à paris il ya
quelques années chez des patients
épileptiques dont les crises commence
dans les régions motrice du cerveau ils
ont découvert un motif très rare dans la
population générale et qui ironie de la
nature ressemble au motif qu'on trouve
sur le bouton sur lequel vous appuyer
pour allumer ordinateurs ou les
appareils électriques
est ce que fait mon équipe depuis des
années c'est essayer de multiplier ce
genre de découverte par exemple avec cet
écran géant qui nous permet de naviguer
dans une base aujourd'hui de 50000
cerveau nous sommes comme des
explorateurs qui ont découvert un coffre
gigantesque plein de livres écrits avec
des idéogrammes étrange et on essaye de
faire un dictionnaire et on a un mal fou
probablement parce que ces idéogrammes
ses livres ils ont été écrits à la main
par des gens différents et que les
idéogrammes sont déformés qui se
ressentent pas tant que ça en fait ça
dépasse l'entendement humain ce problème
et si on en restait là si on était seul
on n'aura aucune chance de devenir des
espèces de champollion des plis du
cerveau mais nous avons un allié de
poids une catégorie des algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle qui est
capable de brasser des milliers voire
des millions de cerveau et qui est en
train de générer les pages de cette
étude soudain ce dictionnaire est pour
vous faire comprendre un peu plus
concrètement notre quotidien je vais
passer un objet d'étude beaucoup plus
simple les plis qu'on trouve dans les
lignes de la main j'aimerais que chacun
d'entre vous essaye de trouver dans sa
main gauche 2-2 ligne particulière une
qui s'appelle la ligne de tête qui est
censée refléter des spécificités de
votre intellect et une autre qui
s'appelle la ligne de coeur qui
correspond plus à vos émotions
ne regardez pas votre ligne de vie c'est
du stress inutile
alors je subodore que dans la salle il
ya des gens pour qui c'est difficile
c'est mon cas et comme aujourd'hui je
dévoile tout je vais vous montrer ma
main gauche pour vous comprendre vous
faire comprendre pourquoi vous pouvez
constater que ma main gauche elle n'est
pas comme la carte routière que je vous
ai montré avant alors je vous laisse
extrapolé sur ce que ça veut dire sur ma
personnalité profonde
heureusement ma main droite est beaucoup
plus standard ça compense alors bien sûr
pour la plupart d'entre vous dirai
peut-être la majorité mais certaines
cultures vois pas les choses pareilles
les lignes de la main c'est au mieux un
divertissement il ya aucune raison qu'on
y trouve des informations sur ma
personnalité profonde voir sur mon
avenir
et pourtant regardez attentivement c'est
demain c'est les mains d'une personne
qui a une maladie génétique très très
grave
et dans les deux mains vous voyez de
motif que j'ai dans ma main gauche et
dans cette maladie c'est le cas de la
majorité des malades alors il ya
peut-être encore des gens dans la salle
qui regardent leurs mains qui commencent
à s'inquiéter
rassurez vous on trouve ce pattern
double dans une partie faible mais une
partie de la population qui est
absolument pas malades et pourquoi ça
arrive ça c'est parce que les jeunes qui
sont à l'oeuvre pendant le développement
des mains
ce sont les mêmes jeunes que ceux qui
créent et qui construisent notre cerveau
bien sûr je vais pas aller beaucoup plus
loin dans la direction début de la
manche ce que je voulais c'est semer un
peu le trouble dans vos convictions pour
augmenter les chances que vous tiriez
quelque chose de mon exposé et pour
finir je voudrais vous ramenez loin en
arrière à une époque de votre enfance
vous n'aviez pas encore appris à lire
souvenez vous quand vous vous promenez
dans une vieux vous voyez des mots écrit
un peu partout et ça a évoqué rien pour
vous c'était des espèces de graphisme
étrange
en fait vous pouvez pas vous souvenir il
ya quelques jours ma fille m'a raconté
que autrefois quand je lisais des
histoires elle pensait que les inventer
elle ne pouvait pas croire que ses
graphismes permettait de raconter
l'histoire
et cette sensation en fait pour
l'ensemble d'entre nous elle est loin
dans le passé elle a disparu à jamais
parce qu'en fait on peut absolument pas
empêché son cerveau de lire ce qui est
écrit
alors si ça vous rend un peu triste et
que vous êtes nostalgique
vous pouvez quand on a essayé d'aller
faire un tour dans un quartier chinois
vous allez peut-être la retrouver cette
sensation
et pourquoi cette métaphore parce que si
jamais l'intelligence artificielle comme
je le prédis arrive à faire résonner nos
millions de cerveau il va se passer une
transition du même ordre
demain on pourra plus regarder un
cerveau naïvement comme on l'a fait
ensemble aujourd'hui parce qu'il y aura
un langage qui se moquera dessus et
j'espère que je vais convaincu que ce
sera pour le mieux que l'intelligence
artificielle va réellement nous aider à
mieux prendre soin de nos cerveaux mais
surtout je voudrais que vous oubliez pas
que vous avez aussi la main vous pouvez
décider de ce que va devenir votre
cerveau en choisissant votre
comportement de la meilleure des façons
merci
[Applaudissements]